man mexican people work
work hard as hell man i got to be honest
with you
never no complaining just work hard
i mean just dude i went to a funeral
of a mexican guy he climbed out of the
casket dug his own grave hole
and then got back in the casket man
i mean just no complaining grind grind
get the job
done man i'll be honest i'm not saying
other people don't but
if i have if i got to do something
for example i need to build a picnic
table or a
you know edible seating structure
you know table and i got
i got nine people to help me do it
if six out of the nine people are
mexican bro
on delay papa we getting it done i'm
telling you that dude
i'm telling you that we're gonna be
eating lunch early
as a group yeah cause that table's gonna
be
a fee knee baby finished
um i just wanted i just you know that's
been on my heart
it's been on my heart that
mexican people just damn
you know it's just i mean it's inspiring
when i see it
just uh you know i see look i saw a
mexican guy cut down a tree
make it into wood bars bars of wood
and then use the wood to make a heat he
built a damn tree with it
i mean that's how they just it's
non-stop
man and s inspira
inspiracional papa
man i'm so excited to be here today and
i'm so excited that i'm not alone
uh that you're here with me we got a
special episode let's get into it
[Music]
yup you think i won't play it again baby
i'll be playing again
let me shine
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
now we gone come on
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like
these leaves i must be cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it in my bones
but it's gonna take a little time
for me to set that parking brake and
left myself on my
let's go
[Music]
man that song that's one of those
you know that song honestly make me grab
my nuts a little
man and i squeeze them when i grab them
i'll be honest with you i don't want to
lie about this
this song make me grab my bag baby and
just
and just put a little dang elbow
just make them
make those make that make those fellas
whistle bruh
i'll squeeze it back
you could hear one of your nuts go
and you know dude when you're not you
got to think about that
when you squeeze your nuts they get they
don't know what's up
one of them's like and you always got
that one scared nut he kind of hides in
the back like
oh oh yeah that's coming oh [ __ ]
and the one just stays up there and he's
kind of brave but he still feels that
squeeze
[Music]
but that's that bad grabber baby right
there that's bishop gunn
with shine and i'm happy to be here
today with you and i really am
you know i'm just feeling
damn
never ends that email it never ends
and that's one of my damn pet peeves bro
besides pets is just
miscellaneous emails you know what i'm
saying it's night time right who's
sending me something
remember best buy used to send those
emails at like
12 p.m oh you need a new
seven disc changer
stop on in
who needs this first generation ipod
you can dude it runs on your pulse
long as you're alive you can listen to
some damn uh
goo goo dolls what what
and it's midnight you trying to finish a
school paper or finish
uh you know doing a contract or
something
a business you know document
a damn x file or whatever it's called
but best buy would be right on time with
that email
at midnight hey
you don't you need an oven
don't you and melanie need an oven like
[ __ ] [ __ ]
men we ate four hours ago and y'all
emailing me about these
convention ovens man just
that's the problem with email
it's like somebody knocking on your door
that doesn't own a watch
and don't know how the sun work
hey no
that's what i'm saying no
i um yeah i'm just saying that that
some songs that make you squeeze your
body like that
and the reason they do it is because
you're trying to if a man i'll say i'm
going to say this correctly
if a man squeezes himself on his nuts
he's it's almost like i'm saying hey man
i want to put a little more life into
the world
because you trying to excuse us like you
something makes you bring you so much
joy i just want to
you know i want to get as much i just
want to squeeze a little more
into the why just i want more life to
hear this
you know i want all i want everything in
my bag to come to the top
top of me to i want all the hidden
little semens inside of me and seeds and
little
you know uh birth hopefuls
to swim out to the front of my skin and
just
absorb whatever i'm absorbing i want
them to feed i want them to hear the
music
i want to hear one of them little you
know
a little semen or something a little
whatever they call a little
one of them little nut parakeets you
know one of them little
slippery heroes i want them to just
i want to just see his little him
putting his little
ear or whatever up to the dang edge of
my stomach on the inside and hearing the
i want them to be out there that's what
i'm saying hey wake up fellas
get out here and listen to what i'm
enjoying
oh but i'm glad to be here with you
today i hope you're having a wonderful
day here it's the beginning of september
and this you know
man i'll say this this was the first
week i started to feel
like i was pretending with the pandemic
anybody else feel that
yeah like i just i started to feel like
i was like i have this mask i wear it
and i do the mask i wear it
you know but i started to feel like is
it
it started to feel real truman showy to
me i just had this moment
i was like is this what's going on it
just felt
like i'm pretending
i don't know if anybody else had that
feeling and i don't know everything of
what it is you know
i just felt like am i pre
i don't know you know when you pretend
something you feel like you're
pretending something
if you pretend to be a wolf you know
then you you might do some things you
might piss on the floor or whatever you
know eat out of a little dish or
something
if you're real young if you like a
little
but if you were like a young wolf or
whatever you pretending
you know but if but you're just
pretending
but you know you're pretending i'm
pretending to be a wolf right now i'm
crawling on four legs and i'm
you know mom's not home and i'm peeing
over here behind this little
you know chifforobe that she keeps a
dictionary on but
um so i don't know i just had this
feeling
the other day like am i pretending that
this is all real
it was interesting just had that feeling
um but you know i wanted to think about
uh
i wanted to think about you know we sent
in we sent a lot of people to space
and they just sent two fellows to space
two i think white guys probably i don't
know
um you know how america is these days
hey we gotta get rid of these white dude
right if i can don't send us anywhere
but they just sent two white uh they
sent two guys from florida into space
and that right there is just
you know i don't understand why are we
going to space all the time
no we can't handle we we can't handle
[ __ ] here
you know two out of two out of seven
americans can't swim
and we out there getting in the deep end
of the of the galaxy with
no floaties on bro you see what they
send these dudes out there in
this thing like a damn 84 uh chevy
blazer sometimes a bit the
the thing they send these dudes out
there
you know and it i just don't understand
what we're doing
it's so lit like i'm not saying it's not
fun to think about what's out there but
i just all am i just sending people to
space
we send two dudes out of florida a
couple spring break addicts every time
down here in florida we blasting two bad
boys out there
it's like come on going to
space the moon that's the thing oh we
want we had
a couple fellas on the moon
dude being on the moon is kind of like
that guy that gets on your
like at a pool party who gets up on the
roof of the house
he's like come on look at me bro
you ain't doing much up there buddy
there ain't nothing up there for you man
and it seems like a cool idea he's
climbing up yeah yeah
yeah then he gets up there it's like man
there's no vending machines there
there's only the opportunity for real
failure
you know there's only you're going to
end up in the white section of world
star hip-hop videos daddy
i'm just saying man it's time to get
back to the roots
we gotta focus on our own little space
that's going on here
that's what i need to do i know that man
i got to focus more on my own
i'm out here doing all of this well
you know letting my thoughts go off to
mars and do this and that and that's
good it's fun
but man i need to i want to get back to
the roots
and that's what i wanted to do today man
with this episode you know um
you know when the podcast started out we
used to really do some stuff for single
moms and
and i know a lot of listeners are raised
by single moms and stuff out there and
uh
and that's always had a big place in my
heart um and a lot of your hearts as
well and so
you know today we wanted to reach out to
some of the some of some of the single
moms that we've met over the years
of um of being a part of this past
weekend
and and touch him with them and see
what's going on in their lives you know
there's a busy time in their lives with
the
they got children going back to
you know they got uh you know they're
sitting here during they got a damn
you know they got the disease in the air
or wherever
and so it's a good chance to be able to
check in with uh
um with these beautiful ladies so let's
get into that now right now uh
let's get into it we got a zoom actually
this is going to be live we got a zoom
coming in here with breezy
from utah
and let's see if we can get her on here
and
we went to an escape room over there
man and i'm so thankful that i'm
thankful that
we're getting to do this today i really
am
i really am you know i during a lot of
this pandemic i just
man i got scared you know i got really
scared about my own
business and you know i was just i just
worked so hard to get to be in a
in a space with comedy where i could
really survive and make a living
and then this happened and so i started
to get real scared and
and honestly man i got real angry a lot
of times um
and uh just just
and i and just didn't make me feel good
and
and it's hard for me to make other
people feel good when i when i'm in a
place of
of just anger
you know you know and especially a lot
happen in society on the news and stuff
it makes you
it feeds into that oh here's a reason to
be angry here's a reason to be angry
but i don't want to be that i just don't
want to be it
you know got me getting angry at people
that i care about just angry at
just i don't know
it's not worth it's not worth it
so here we got a beautiful lady right
here hey breezy can you hear me
what's going on how are you oh i'm
really
i'm really good how are you doing i'm
doing pretty well you look lovely today
thank you we're getting i'm getting
ready to take the kids to a movie
oh okay at a movie theater yes they're
only playing older movies we're going to
go see the original back to the future
oh that'd be nice for them huh that's
yeah one of my favorites show them what
it was like back in the day when uh when
a man had to wear a puffy vest and still
look like a decent man you know
yes um what's been going on so you
are you guys have been during this
pandemic how's it been because you have
three children right
i have three my son just left today he's
moving to wyoming to finish his senior
year with his best friends with his dad
oh wow that's was that kind of sad or
how did you feel about it
i had a good cry
two to go and is he a decent kid is he
pretty decent
oh my kids are the best kids you have no
idea i don't know how they wound up
so good they're really really
good-hearted
amazing respectful kids who make good
decisions i don't know what happened to
them
it wasn't me wow are you sure they're
kids because that doesn't sound like
kids at all
they're they're not normal kids i'm
telling you
um so what what did you guys do during
this was it pretty rough out there for
you guys during this um
during the quarantine and all of this
kind of stuff how was it over there in
utah
it was rough work out really hard i lost
my hours
unemployment wasn't paying for a minute
i wound up joining
only fans i started my own only fans
and um since then everything's been
better we don't have everything open yet
so we're still just stuck inside but
um time's all hard for a minute but
everything's flicking up now and
it's starting to open up a little bit
yeah i mean yeah so uh
so wait so yeah obviously things yeah
things got tougher people so you open up
an only fans
like a provocateur female provocateur
kind of
environment exactly
wow okay it was i i wasn't sure at first
if it was something that i wanted to do
but it's been really successful and i
made it to the top eight percent
oh wow so yeah so this is just you
needed some you
look you got to be able to survive you
have three children um
yeah i i i support that that's i
probably won't look at it
um that's okay okay don't ask me what's
on it because you're going to have to
pay for it if you want to know
okay uh yeah look
my imagination can probably i mean i
have no idea
i'm sure it's wonderful i think it's
really cool um that you
are figuring out ways to to make things
happen during this you know
uh yeah really really good and uh
yeah i'm just i'm kind of torn because i
know like i try not to
venture into the wild you know into the
wat into the wilds of the web
not for everybody so that's okay i i
respect that
and i respect that you have it and i
know that we can still support it
and not and and and i don't have to go
there out of
you know not out of uh i wish i wish
everybody
thought like that what uh what is it
well
yeah what is it do you feel like sharing
that is that okay
yeah no absolutely i just i share nude
photos explicit photos and
sometimes video clips oh wow no no what
do you is there a link or something
where people
are just uh that's what i meant no no i
can guess what it is
is there a link or not i don't want to
like i'm just saying if people
look here's what i'm saying i support
the fact that mom's got to do what mom's
got to do
and look it's a tough time i love it i'm
glad that you are
finding ways to provide and if we have
listeners that even i'm not going to
tell those
young fellas to get out there and watch
it but if they want to support it
where can they support it they can go to
only fans you can
search me on instagram on only fans and
on tick tock
um under havana gypsy all the same names
on any of those three and you can find
my only fans through those other social
media
havana gypsy huh let's see
that comes out here only fans and so
and was that something that do your did
the kids know about that
my kids know about it my they haven't
seen it but they do
well yeah they all know about it even my
youngest now knows
wow my daughter's in she's behind the
camera my my middle's here with me yes
she knows about it
oh well look that's wild i mean
you look i love it you know people put
their artwork out there
uh you know beauty is a form of art and
the female body is a form of art and i
love it
absolutely so what about is it is there
more pressure now that the sun
is gone like who's gonna step up and be
kind of like the
the next in command there at the house
my daughter's like she knows it's her
she's
my second hand anyway before him even i
always
called her to help me with everything so
um she's here with me
oh anybody i guess is here you know
they're all just really good at help
they they'll help me they all hug me
when i need it they're good kids
man god i love that i wish they would
have raised me i feel like
there's still time there's still time
and i still need to be raised as well i
think um
so what uh did your family feel like get
closer over this pandemic did do you
feel like it was kind of a tough did you
feel like it didn't help what were some
things that kind of happened as a family
unit
um me and my kids or me and my siblings
yeah maybe you and your kids the kids
and i
we've been i mean same i've been home
more because
part of my my nightlife my going out you
know having friends and having things to
do and so
that's all closed down so i've been at
home you know more
um but we really we just do the same
thing we've always done you know we just
hang out at home we'll put on movies and
kind of just hang out that's what we do
but
we have been going roller skating they
open the roller skating rink back up so
we've been doing that too
i love that god i love that
and does your daughter kind of meet men
at the roller skating rink or does she
do
dating or what's her does she do she
just had a boy
how old is he he's 18
18 year old picker up the other day and
they went to see a movie
oh my god don't tell me he was a
comedian was he a comedian i think i
know him
that was her first kind of date um
and that that was fun but no she have
you know anybody
she's had a few friends at the skating
rink but no boys and were you nervous
about her going on this date how did
that was that kind of a fun thing what
was that like
no i wasn't nervous she had fun they
just they just hung out she
actually knew him from school he
graduated last year um so she knew him
from school so i wasn't nervous
as long as she knows him and feels
comfortable enough to go with him she's
got her phone she can call me if
she needs anything and she knows that so
i wasn't nervous she had a good time
dang that's cool you guys are lit you
guys are like few you guys are like this
future family i feel like in a strange
way
you guys have a lot going on just so it
just seems just
i don't know maybe i'm just living a
boring life but um
well hopefully whenever yeah when comedy
opens back up we'll have to come in and
check in and get to bring you out to
another show i hope you do i would love
it
yeah we certainly will and uh yeah we're
gonna send something over to want to do
something nice you can do something fun
with the kids and
um or the one less kids now but um
well look it's nice to see you and i
hope you guys have a wonderful time at
the movie
it's so good to see you hear from you
you're an awesome guy i had a lot of fun
on our singles night out
yeah we'll have to do it again
any love interests over there any love
during the pandemic for mom or what's
that like
listen i don't know i i don't know
okay we'll leave it at that to be
continued
there might be something just barely
starting we'll see
okay well i'm gonna keep my fingers
crossed for that um
awesome well uh thank you so much breezy
for for just check it for
checking in and chatting with us and uh
and i hope you guys have a wonderful
um whatever it is a month a day a year
everything
thank you it's good to hear from you all
right you too i'll talk to you soon
all right thank you okay bye bye
hey hey today's episode is brought to
you by
ship estation hey guys i gotta
ship something wow
use ship station
look the world is changing you might
have to deliver this you might have to
deliver that you know
who knows what you got to do we're all
going to be buying more stuff online
though
i think that's evident and if you're an
e-commerce
seller are you ready to meet the demands
of our new delivery
culture be ready with shipstation
why shipstation well when you're selling
online getting a lot of orders
fast can be tough well shipstation is
the fastest
easiest and most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders
they work with all the major carriers
including usps fedex ups and even amazon
fulfillment
shipstation is the number one choice of
online sellers
and right now you can support the
podcast
our listeners can try shipstation for
free for 60 days when you use offer code
theo that's right make sure your
business is ready to meet the demands of
delivery culture
get started at shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in theo
that's right click on the microphone at
the top of the home page
and type in theo look you've got a new
business
get it done right that's shipstation.com
then enter offer code t-h-e-o
shipstation.com
make ship happen look my first
experience with cologne i didn't know
what it was
and everybody knows cologne is just
something they beat the smell out of
something put in a little can
and now it's yours man
and the first time i got it i didn't
know i'd only seen breath
spray breath cologne you know just
minting your mouth up
so i seen it somebody had a thing of
that colon you know
so i hit myself in a mouth real quick
about five or six squirts of uh
of um uh ck1 louis ck1
and dang bro let me tell you this
my breath smelled like cologne my cereal
tasted like cologne
for about two months amen baby praise
god
that's why i'm here to tell you about
hawthorne
hawthorne look you take a quick
two minute quiz and hawthorne tells you
the two colognes that are best for you
based on your body type body style
activities whatever everything
the quiz covers it all hawthorne is
totally risk-free
with free shipping and free returns
it's easy check out hawthorne
at hawthorne.co yep
that's hawthorne with an e
h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot c-o and use my promo code
theo to get ten percent off your first
purchase
that's h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot and use my code theo to get
10 off your first purchase
hawthorne dot co smell good
they got great ingredients it's
convenient it's easy to buy online
luxurious packaging quality
they got everything from skin care to
scent care
hawthorne.co and use code theo
wow so look
look it's the 21st injury what you know
what i'm saying these ladies out there
mom's got to survive she's got three
little ones
i'ma support uh look we put our support
behind single moms
and so you can support breezy you know
and uh
and that's you know that's why it's
different times
you know mama gotta earn the bread
that's it that is it like look
at least she's out there making money
too i remember
dude i remember some a mechanic feeling
my mom up for free
so this ain't that baby those days are
over um
so maybe [ __ ] i would have nick get us
a membership but dang
me or him doesn't need any of that in
our lives really we got
and i'm not saying i don't i just i got
dude i open my eyes and i see them
you know 30 50 vaginas and titties and
booties
bhs man buttholes you know what so i got
enough of that in my head and my damn
jug right floating around
so i'm trying to log off of my own
thoughts half the time
but um
but yeah i am envious of that
relationship just having that
open relationship with your kids
um
[Music]
you know i think i am envious of that i
think there's some things that
well i don't know maybe there's
something you want kids to know
something you don't but
man i i i remember i was i kept
everything a secret when i was a kid
everything
everything was a secret i would get you
know i remember i'd get me a little bit
of money
doing uh
doing odd jobs or something real odd
you know we had this old lady by us we
used to steal our cats
and then we would keep them long enough
till she you know
we'd help her write up a wanted poster
you know wanted little caramel
you know wanted little quagmire you know
two dollars on there
and then we put the poster up outside
two days later bring that little bastard
back and get the money
and i don't know if she knew we were
doing it or not she had to have now i
mean
i don't know she might had alzheimer's i
mean she might have had
this back they didn't have alzheimer's
then they said all that you know
oh that [ __ ] is nuts that's what they
would say
and i didn't say that i wouldn't say
something like that
but they'd be you know somebody drive by
oh that bitch's nut
and i wouldn't say it man cause i don't
say you know i wouldn't say that kind of
stuff i was a child
and plus i was you know you know i was
extraditing cats or whatever it's called
you know laundering cat money you know
living that wildlife
so who am i to judge a single mother out
there
laundering cat money you feel me gang
gang
baby oh
um let's get into another call we got
another single mom on the line
and i remember we went well i'll just
get on with her
what's going on with you we had such a
good time with uh you and your sister
went on the go-karts that was such a
blast i thought
i know we and her were just talking
about it too
and we did we had such a good we're just
getting ready for school all this
craziness i don't even know what's going
on anymore
i know i just had this feeling yesterday
like what is going
on anymore people are wearing some of
these masks aren't even
like like what is going on
i know it's i feel like well it is what
happened my kids went on spring break
and
haven't been back to school since so
it's been like one really long
drawn-out spring break and have they
do you feel like they want to go back to
school or they do they feel like school
doesn't even exist anymore what's it
kind of like from their perspective
it's been it was really hard at the
beginning because
they didn't understand like explaining
to them
that i think at first they were like
excited they didn't have to go
they were okay with it then they
realized that
it's not a vacation like you have to do
school
and we can't go anywhere you can't see
your friends
and probably in the first month everyone
just went it stirred crazy like and it
got depressing we couldn't go to the
i couldn't take them to the store and i
had to keep explaining to them that
we really can't go anywhere you you
can't go anywhere
i can't go anywhere yeah this is we're
stuck
together and this is how it's going to
be for a while
so it's been like waves of like oh
you're excited and then it gets
depressing and
yeah now it's like i still don't know
what to tell them because
school is gonna be
two days um
in person and three online
so it's like it's not even going to go
back to the way it was
why it seems so bizarre i feel like i
can't plan for anything
and then they moved school back to it
was supposed to start this coming up
week
and then they moved it back to september
8th so
i've been getting to a point where i
forget it's happening
and i get in a panic like is school
school starting tomorrow
like did i miss something so yeah it has
been
really confusing every day i'm like holy
[ __ ] is tomorrow christmas like
is it today my mom's birthday like i
never i don't know what any
yeah every day it's just everything it's
like oh [ __ ] i gotta do this
i don't know what's going on yeah do i
need a flu shot am i supposed to go to
the emergency room like
what do i do today i almost forgot what
grade they're in
like who cares give them all give them
all diplomas
and let them work at home depot yes
i mean the last time they went into
school they had no idea this was going
to be the last day
of elementary school it was their last
day of middle school right
and nobody knew we just thought oh we're
going on spring break and then all of a
sudden yeah
you're not coming back so do you feel
like there could be like
like mental effects from that or do you
feel like that they're pretty resilient
like i would
it almost feels like you don't even get
to tell your friends bye and stuff i
guess you're gonna see them again but it
seems bizarre
i feel like my mental health has been
impacted quite a bit
um and yeah i felt it started to make me
really sad because
i could see the shift in their behavior
like i could see especially my older
kids because i have a 16 year old
daughter and my son
is about to be 15. those two i think
it's been the hardest for those two
wow well and my youngest boy has autism
and this dude likes things to be the
same
he likes to know what to expect and when
he likes structure and all of a sudden
there's none
so getting back into a regular pattern
they've done
they did a really great job at home
though i mean for having five of them
they did i was impressed by how good
they did but they were
i could they were starting to get sad
and then that makes me sad because it's
like
i and i can't do anything you cannot fix
it
i'm like oh we can go on a walk how many
times can you walk around the
neighborhood
yeah without being a peeping tom yeah
that's my question you know
yeah you don't want to be a family of
peeping toms that's the most
embarrassing thing you could be like
check out the weirdos are coming around
again
the crazy lady with all those yeah
they're all flashers now
do um has it gotten um
do you feel like where do you feel like
y'all's morale is right now like um
are they excited at least to be going
back for the two days
the kids like a through h are going
um on one block of time
and then the other kids are going so
alternate shifts so
the my kids will go tuesday and friday
god
yeah everybody does homeschool on
wednesday
then the other so if their friends have
different last you know the last name
doesn't fall they don't get to go to
school with their friends
and then for me my anxiety has been off
the charts
like so yeah it's been the more i it i
don't even know
i don't even know what to call it
anymore like i don't know how to feel
i don't know what to do or what to think
it is the most bizarre
long drawn out thing i've ever it's yeah
and i don't know what to
i tell the kids all the time like my mom
didn't do this
my mom's mom didn't do this we're
figuring this out together don't be mad
at me
because i am it's new i'm trying i don't
know what else to do
yeah so yeah it has been
it's been really overwhelming i think i
was okay until
because i kept telling myself that
school's gonna start and things are
gonna go back to normal
and then as soon as they started making
the announcements about school
i realized that this [ __ ] is never going
away
and it's it might be worse because
expecting them to be like this at school
like i just feel bad for all of them
it's just such a it's a weird space to
be in it is
for them for me yeah i don't know what
to do and i don't the right thing to do
is like i don't want anyone
to be sick i don't want my kids to get
sick but at the same time you have to
live
like yeah this is not i agree at a
certain
sometimes it doesn't feel like living
it's like and hopefully we'll get to
some better meetings
yeah yeah we're yeah we're surviving um
i agree
i agree sometimes i'm like man i'd
rather just take my chance and just
live um but we'll deal with it when it
if it happens i i'll be careful
when it happens you just deal with it i
think too my kids had a lot of health
problems when they were younger so i've
been through a lot of
nasty stuff anyway so
i feel like i can handle
quite a bit and we'll just it's i've
lived one day at a time for so long
that i can do it like we'll just see
what happens
and we're gonna be okay but not
it's the unknown if you you can serve me
anything like any
big load of [ __ ] but if i know what i'm
dealing with
right i can get through it yeah not
knowing what i'm dealing with
it's i don't like it yeah there's
something about
yeah they don't let you yeah they just
they just keep
serving your [ __ ] but they're not really
letting you you know bring your diapers
every day
they used to let us bring our diapers
every day and they're just not doing
they're
they're not yeah and they give me some
tools to navigate this [ __ ]
and i'll do it yeah but don't don't let
me as a mother don't have me wake up
every day
and not yeah that's a lot of pressure i
didn't really realize how much that is
on a mom especially when you
when you start to think about the how
it's affecting your kids and
and the life you want them to have just
as just as humans as
as human beings it's hard enough with
kids now i think like uh
social media their friends their ages
that they're at because all of my kids
are like
it's like a puberty sandwich they're
either coming through it coming out of
it or going into it
praise god man this [ __ ] is wise factory
oh so yeah
seriously so we're we're going through
that now like all
one of them will go to bed a sweet angel
and they'll wake up and i don't know who
this jerk
is yep that's puberty right there then
you throw this on top of it and it's
like wow
that's a 100 perberty right there
there's no reason to be depressed
yeah your son wake up with a damn
mustache and suddenly
you know he says he works at a coal mine
you're like you know what
who is this man it's in my house
yeah his boyfriend is and he'll be he'd
be so embarrassed but when his voice
started to change
i would seriously be like who is the man
in the hallway who is because i didn't
recognize it for so long that's it
and he'll like grow an inch every other
day every time he comes out of his room
i'm like this is a new
nice to meet you i know that's crazy
puberty man it's that freaking game it's
a yeah that's a dirty game show man it's
wild
when you get into puberty that shit's
wild well look well and i feel like
i'm losing every day it's just well
you're not
i think you uh here's one thing that i
definitely remember
is that you have a really good sense of
humor and i'm sure that that goes over
so much more than somebody that does it
well we want to send you
like just a little gift to something
nice you can go do whenever you do have
all the kids uh
you know whenever anybody's not going
through anything real crazy i can go do
something fun and
um yeah just good to check in and just
see your face and just
i know um i was so excited this it like
made my whole it makes this whole thing
so much better
it's like uh thank you it breaks it up
some
um oh yeah but whenever i come you guys
got to take me well i'll go out and do
something again that was a lot of fun
oh my gosh i would that would be so
amazing me and maggie talk about it
often and yeah she's she'd have to come
too so
oh let's get that's what i'm saying
let's get some real card you know what
i'm saying let's rent a couple honda
accords and get some real wheels going
it's grown-up time yeah that's what i'm
saying
let's freaking roll up a joint and get
some real wheels going
that's what i'm talking about later kids
yeah yeah see you later kids you're
gonna have to stay in the trunk
um well look francesca good to talk to
you and
you look lovely and um and please tell
your sister that we said hey as well and
uh
and thanks for just jumping on and
chatting with us and just being a part
of our day it really is nice
no i appreciate it i've been thinking
about you guys too and thank you for
thinking of me it like
it really made my weekend oh you're
welcome uh us too hearing you say that
uh really made my day so thank you so
much
y'all take care and uh we'll let you
know whenever we're coming back near
kansas city
look i'm trying to find new auto
insurance you know because i want to
stay insured and be
insured i want both and it's hard
it's hard but policy genius
yeah i said it policy genius
they save their home and auto customers
an average of
one thousand one hundred and twenty
seven dollars a year
by shopping top rated
insurers in one place all you have to do
is go to policygenius.com
and answer a few quick questions about
your property
after that policy genius does all the
work
they'll compare your existing policy
against others in the market
to make sure you're getting the right
coverage at the best possible
price if they find a better rate than
what you're currently paying
they'll get you switched over for free
so you don't have to do it
they'll do it that kind of service has
earned policy
genius a five-star rating across 600
reviews on
trustpilot and google so if you're a
homeowner
head to policygenius.com right now to
get
started they've saved their home and
auto insurance customers an average of
eleven hundred
twenty seven dollars a year that's
enough money to go on a kind of
semi-decent vacation or go camping
who knows what weirdly specific amount
they can save you
policygenius.com and now back to the
episode
man i love the resiliency of these women
you know francesca sitting there saying
she got two twins and two kids in their
teens and just
you know to show up every day every day
every day
in an environment where you don't they
don't even tell you if you have any
tools in your box every day
and to show up man that is
just for anybody it doesn't matter if
it's a mother or what's going on it just
man i'm lucky to be talking with these
women today
i'm lucky to be reminded of
of what it takes i really
am um oh awesome we have nikki
uh and nikki and i met in san jose
and she brought her lovely friend out
and we went out to get some ice cream
uh frozen yogurts and she's the owner of
trim scene in arcata california
hey nikki hey hey what's up how are you
good how are you i'm doing good you look
so pretty
oh thanks yay it's good to see you it's
always a treat when i get a message from
you or
uh nick oh that's sweetie to say that
thank you
um yes nice to see you as well what's
going on up there
uh well i'm not in humble right now i'm
in ohio
oh okay what happened you uh tell me
um so nothing really happened i just
um kind of always had a plan once my
oldest graduated high school which
happened
in june so yeah i got one
yeah um but i would come back you know
my family um
is all here and uh
um so kind of do like a back and forth
thing yeah
um almost like you were talking about
with your nashville
but uh true it's it's scary it's
it's yeah how's it been has it been um
did you have a lot of expectations has
it been harder than you thought has it
been
like what ways has it been tough in what
ways has it been good
um well it's been tough just saying you
know just leaving
my routine my business yeah trim scene
is is
are you still trimming yeah yeah oh good
so i still have the business
and then you know i'm to go back every
couple months so it's nice to still have
my foot in california
because you know california we love
california i know look at there's a
there's a there's a lot of nice things
so yeah it's nice to be able to do both
right um and you know it's hard just um
just acclimating just uh
you know i'm i i'm
not in my own home at the moment
although like i'm in contract i might
buy my first home
that's kind of a big scary deal
and um and you know just being around
family i already see it paying off
in ways of like um like my sons being
around my dad who like you know they've
not been raised around him i've been
across the country and
just getting um knowledge and learning
things from him that i can't give them
you know and just uh just a broader
spectrum of exposure
i think i think it's going to be good
even though it's
can be scary wow it's so brave yeah no
it's funny you say that
similar to kind of like doing with with
uh trying out nashville yeah it's like
yeah it's it's it's scary but all
all i can do is just kind of be hopeful
with it and
and make the most out of it and also
then
i can be excited about it it's like
there's two ways i can do it every every
day
i wake up wherever i am i can either you
know
give in to kind of the tough parts of it
or i can be like man i'm excited about
right possibility yeah i'm learning so
much about reframing
like i love it it's it's it's it it
works i think
yeah i like that yeah
i think it does work yeah it's so true
it's like i think sometimes if i say if
oh i have to do this and then if i can
change it sometimes to say i get to do
this no matter what it is
um then it can really really just help
me have a different experience um
i think a lot of people it's so funny a
lot of my friends have been messaging me
about
moving and going back to you know some
of their home towns or places where
their family lives
i'm having a lot of friends who are
doing that right now
um well i think with everything going on
in the world
right it's like it's comforting it's
comforting to be supported
yeah yeah that's a good way to say it it
really is
um yeah there's something that's it's
almost like the rat race has kind of
been exposed like for like
what am i you know i don't mind being a
rat but what am i really racing for
right no i totally get that and just um
yeah it's brought a lot of things of
like what is important what is really
important what do i want my days to look
like what do i
um what what do i want you know like
um what's up with any new love interests
over there in the ohio world or what's
that been like
um well it's so hard to date in uh in
code vid times right dude a friend of
mine
he went on a date with a woman and she
had
he she made him he had to pick her up
and she sat in the back seat of his car
with her mask on
okay then that's not even the worst part
they went to a restaurant
and she sat at a different table than
him
i think i would feel comfortable like
meeting outside at a park
you know you know yeah look i think it's
slow
yeah take it slow if the guy's not dead
after the second date or you're not dead
i think after that you guys are safe
right if we survive two weeks then
oh yeah then we're good yeah i like that
well you look i mean you look absolutely
stunning who's doing your hair right now
um i'm doing oh actually you know what i
did get a haircut since i've been here
um because i used to work here um i
haven't lived here in 12 years but um
i still have friends in the industry
here so i went and saw
my friend brett brett at hair love in
columbus ohio
oh i like that i had the most relaxing
weekend
i went camping i i mean i
just i didn't have kids all weekend so i
like drove through all these little
towns i stopped where i wanted and
like oh it was so nice to recharge and
to like make yourself
do those things like it doesn't come
easy to like take time out to
just do whatever you feel like doing
because yeah you're in the grind and and
you know
and then it's a snowball and it's it's
hard to like stop yourself right yeah
no it is it's like yeah it's like what
do i want to do like
it's been so long since i really asked
myself like what up really what do i
want to do
you know am i just doing stuff or do i
do i have some dream or some or an
ambition or just a
do i not want to do anything for a
little while like um
so yeah it's just so interesting that
this is going on because there's
there really are some positives in all
of this uh
you know that i don't even know if we
know what they are all the time but
but i know i do know that they're there
right well isn't that like supposed to
be the thing where like uh
some of the worst experiences of your
life
ended up being like set you know some of
the best
yeah the blessing i learned oh yeah they
always say that
that old cheesy saying but it's kind you
know it's kind of true yeah my buddy
used to say if somebody serves you a
cert
if you if somebody serves you a satan
sandwich at least you still got a
sandwich you know
right right reframe it yeah at least you
still got that sandwich
um well look we we wanted to send
something just like a nice gift and just
like so you could just do something like
just small and fun for yourself
and just let you know that we're
thinking of you and um
and um i'm just proud of you i feel like
it's cool like it kind of makes me feel
a little bit
it just reminds me about my own little
adventure and like
you know i got to stay positive oh sorry
you just went quiet and i didn't hear
what you said
after you said you were proud of me i'm
gonna need you to repeat that
okay let me see if i can remember um
no it just it it just reminds me that i
gotta i have to remember that yeah i can
do this instead of like
because i'll a couple times a day i'll
get scared like oh
you know is everything gonna be okay
with you know having a studio here
having
a studio somewhere else and what if i
have a couple of guests and it doesn't
work out and
and i feel uncomfortable in the town and
then i don't know anyone and
um you know and just trying to be but
but but those but i can also look at
things like
hey i'm gonna get to go and you know
maybe try some brazilian jiu jitsu that
i've been wanting to do or i've been
you know maybe i can start some new
patterns because i'll be in a new place
uh you know maybe it'll be easier for me
to be out of my little
goldfish bowl that'll make me you know
see how
you know maybe i can try a different
swim stroke you know since i'm not just
stuck in the same bowl you know
i feel you i feel you i'm learning so
much about myself even just being around
family that i haven't spent this much
time with and
ages and just turning into some deep
ancestral something i mean i don't know
i'm just seeing like
just similarities and like the way we
act and stuff which i've like never
noticed before and just like um
getting back to our roots we're all
getting back to our roots i think right
no matter what no matter what the
natural color of them is i think
we're all getting back to our roots
right
yeah know thyself i guess i don't know
it's good it's good
well i mean you are just dang
uh lovely and if there's anything we can
do to support like
the business or a new business on social
media or something like that just make
sure to
to check in and let us know and um and
we'll be happy to do that
oh thank you theo i appreciate that yeah
and don't feel weird about it either
we want to help out um okay i won't okay
so weird
good i appreciate that um but i'm glad i
got to hear your voice again and i'm
just glad that we got to chat a little
bit and and i'll try and do a better job
also of keeping in touch sometimes
because uh
you know it's just you know we don't
realize sometimes when we reach out to
people
that everybody wants to be reached out
to you know it doesn't matter who it is
if it's an old friend if it's a new
friend
you know everybody wants to be you know
thought of by other people
um so i'm glad that you took the time
today to
to spend some time with us of course
thank you
like i said it's always a tree it's so
exciting i well i
i love checking in with you guys well
that's sweet of you to say and
uh and nikki we'll be in touch and um
and i'll check in with you more often
and you guys be good over there and
thanks for your time
yay thank you good luck theo with all of
your things that you're doing and i love
you
and appreciate you i love you too and i
look forward to seeing you in columbus
or in arcata whenever i uh get near it
okay okay bye bye
it's so funny that uh that nikki does
hair and that we're talking about roots
man
you know that's small that's small ball
but that's big
court um
and just the edge just the bravery man
i'm so lucky
i'm so lucky to to get to talk with
these
women and just to know these people um
we had a couple of other moms that sent
in stuff and
um two other not sending stuff that we
checked in with
and so we want to get to uh their videos
right now they made videos
because mom's schedules can be busy
and it means a lot that they even did
this uh so we have one right here from
raquel and raquel we did we met up
and she is a professor in chicago and
she brought
she has a daughter and she brought out
her friend
to the um we did painting
we made some paintings oh here they are
hold on
and there we go right here and that's a
painting right there
i think it's a lithograph or something i
don't know
it's definitely a painting though but we
made some paintings
and had a little contest a fun painting
contest
and um before the show
at the laugh factory in chicago it's
about a year and a half it was like
really the first weekend of the dark
arts tour
um and so yeah anyhow lucky to have uh
this um video from raquel right here
here we go
what's up theo this is raquel
uh reaching out to you thanking you as
always for
the check-in and for the wonderful
notes and surprises i get we receive
from you throughout the year
you're so thoughtful and kind oh you're
very welcome that's very sweet of you to
say that
um and really nice you to make this
video this looks so
beautiful where you are um
um i'm here in chicago at lake michigan
doing what we do when it's 91 degrees we
come to the lake
fortunate to have a child-free day my
daughter is with
friends that are included in our little
bubble she's out in suburbs at an
outdoor swimming pool
at somebody's house so that's good oh
yeah mom got that day out
i love hearing this um
this is really nice lake michigan i
didn't realize it was that
i mean that's clear water that's
beautiful
i'd get under that water that's nice um
and raquel looking sultry out there too
you got the bathing suit mom's out there
having a good day
i like this let's hear more and
we have survived covid thus far like
everybody else you know the struggles
are real the isolation the six feet
apart the masking up and all that good
stuff
but we've been doing it i'm happy to say
she um
she goes to an independent school so she
is going to be going back to school
um after labor day with about 10 other
kids in her little pod
our school gave us the choice of you
know being remote or in person
and we chose the in-person
option i love that and so
she will be going to school in person i
will continue working from home
and then in november we'll see what's
going on
here at her school it's all a grand
experiment it's all a grand experiment
so
that's what's good with us we are doing
really well
we're doing well i hope you and yours
and your family and all your fans
are doing well too so thank you theo
thank you thank you thank you
enjoy raquel i think you all i think you
definitely win the award for
uh having the best time of the day so
far
um for some of the moms we've been
chatting with and um
i'm happy to hear that your daughter is
is going to be enjoying herself and
getting to go to school
and have some friends and have that
interaction uh
and yeah the struggle is real you know i
think it's been real for
it's been real for a lot of people um
but thank you for taking the time to
share that message and i'm glad you're
having getting to have a day
to yourself or somewhat to yourself i
know a mom's job is never really their
own or
time is never really their own
but really sweet of you
and i'm glad that we still get to keep
in touch and we want to do something
nice we'll
we'll be in touch about that and just um
thank you for being a part of our lives
here on the episode and
on the podcast and with this family uh
we got
one more check-in video right here
and this is from emily from
eau claire wisconsin
uh um let's hear from her
hey theo it's emily from wisconsin we
met almost
two years ago now in minneapolis for
single moms night out
that's crazy and i do remember that uh
and i have some photos too and i'll
drop those into this as we uh go through
your video okay
i'm not too anxious about the fall with
kids going back to school because my son
will be five so he would be in 4k
this year and i'm just
not gonna send him because i'm not okay
with a lot of the things going on right
now with requirements for
wearing masks for school age kids and
it's just something that i don't want to
support because i don't believe in it
whatsoever
well i i i love that i love that you
um yeah i'm sure it's tough you know
moms have to stand by what they feel is
best
and so that's what a mom is and so i'm
glad to see you
uh trusting your instincts i hope other
parents are making the same
decisions and doing the best that they
can but i understand it's not always the
easiest
um no dating for me during this time so
i don't have any good tips or tricks but
i can say
that i moved in with my boyfriend last
year
at the end of last year and this has
really been a time
to force us to work on things and you
know address some things that i
probably wouldn't have in the past i
maybe would have just
dipped and run or found the negative but
i've really relied on him for support
and he's been really helpful with my son
and with my job and everything else so
wow that's really amazing to hear that i
think and i think
i remember you were in chiropractic
chiropractor i believe um
and yeah i mean i think being together
and in those relationships and you got
to figure it out
i mean it's like a damn ufc right now
for relationships it is they close the
cage
and you're in that octagon this is um
it's real bare knuckles these days um
so uh i'm glad to see that you you're
doing well with that
kobe's been great actually financially
um just emotionally spending time with
my family
and my company is opening a second
location
next week that will be mine to run so i
achieved one of my
goals and dreams for my life to have my
own clinic so i'm really excited
thank you so much for all that you do
shout out to my brother who's been sober
over a year
and he just loves and digs your podcast
same with me
kang gang gang gang thank you emily
thank you for uh the video uh
congratulations on your business
that's amazing you know one thing i do
remember about you is that you are very
uh you're a go-getter
you know when um and go-getters get
they do they really do uh
congratulations to your brother
you know just um you know it's obviously
that you really care about him and
i think he even texted me about i think
we we even texted about him once
um but uh
but yeah i saw you also in vegas my mind
got blurry towards
like before covet like the six months
before cove
i don't even know what i was doing a lot
of times um
but congratulations to your brother
congratulations to you we want to send
something nice you know so you could go
do something fun on behalf of the
podcast and
um but that's so cool you're opening
your own clinic
man that's awesome and it sounds like a
lot of great things are happening
in your life and thank you for sharing
them with us
it sounds like you deserve them um
man i'm just so la i didn't realize how
lucky i am to know so many cool chicks
uh yeah i just feel so lucky um
[Music]
and we didn't get to reach out to all
the single moms uh but
you know we we did what we could and and
we just wanted to put together an
episode and so i'm glad we're able to
make this happen
and thank you to all the moms for being
a part of our
uh just a part of our lives in a little
bit of a way
you know i think one thing that i'm
reminded of by all of these women uh
is just
i guess i just feel grateful that they
all cared enough to still
communicate and be a part of the show
and be a part of uh of my life
and in our lives and um
it's cool
you know uh
you know i really just wanted to kind of
get back to the roots of things that
made this podcast feel good to me
when i started um
you know and one of those things has
been
you know connecting with
you know when i was a kid i never got to
i never really
you know you can only talk to you can
only do so much for your mom because
you're a kid
you know you don't get to be a man for
your mother when you're a child
you just get to be a kid
and so often i think
you know you want to be able to be more
but you're just a child
and so it's nice now as an adult that i
can get little pieces of
i don't know what it is
i guess it's selfish in some ways but
it's nice as an adult now that i'm able
to
no it's not well it is selfish i guess
but it's nice that i'm able to interact
with mothers
who were at the point that my mom was
when i was a kid
and just
just let them know that people care you
know
because i think you know when i was a
kid i think i probably wanted someone to
let my mother know that
and
and i and no and there wasn't somebody
around to do it
and i couldn't do it you know i was a
kid it just wouldn't have been
i wasn't thinking that way i was just a
child
you know and i couldn't our relationship
wasn't like that you know
um
[Music]
this just today for me just a nice
reminder of
you know you think about space they got
people in space and
we go looking out there
and you stick you know they put a man in
a damn
you know half of a toyota camry and
shoot him out there
and you know a third of the time the
damn thing the engine
you know blows out on the way up
just looking into the nothing we're just
looking into the
nothing and that's good
but sometimes you know it's just a nice
reminder
you know to get just to touch hold of
the things that are holding on to us
you know to check in with our mothers to
check in with our fathers
to check in with our stepmothers or our
stepfathers or our pseudo mothers even
you know we got a bunch of second-hand
moms here
you know i bet you if you were a tpw fan
or
listener you could walk up to any of
these single moms and
and tell them hello and
and you'd have a special place in their
heart and vice versa
um
and that's just powerful it's just
you know it's just a reminder that you
know it's i don't know if it's a
reminder but it's
you know sometimes we're out there
looking i'm out there looking so hard
for stuff and
and we got you know we out there in
outer space we're out there on saturn
meanwhile we got women here in eau
claire we got people here in
in columbus and arcata
you know we got people here in in
chicago
we got people here in in
um in utah
you know sometimes it's nice just to
know that
or just to remind remember that that
some of that connection that we're out
there hunting all the time is
you know it's it's already there
you know it's our roots
and yeah it just and it's
you know it's nice as a child i couldn't
you know i couldn't do things for my
mother i couldn't tell
i couldn't be a man and tell my mother
how i felt
and now i get to be a man and i can look
back and i can connect with people that
are in the same space and
and just be a part of just letting these
women know that they're loved
that's all and they're not asking for it
they're not
i mean we picked these ladies out of the
damn ether
but but they just return it right back
you know and uh
and i just feel grateful i think just to
know
i don't know i don't know what i feel
exactly but i do i feel good
you know i feel good that
you know when i was a kid there was a
you know i couldn't
i couldn't let my mother know
that i cared as much you know i couldn't
i couldn't help out i didn't have any
means to help
a little even if she wasn't asking for
it to help a little
you know i didn't have the voice i
didn't have the voice as a child to say
you know hey mom you're doing a good job
or i'm you know i just we didn't have
that connection you know we didn't have
it
but i can take that same template
that same missed opportunity that i you
know
and i can apply it now
you know and that's one of the gifts of
of just existence
is to be able to fill in
these spaces of of our past with uh
with the people of um
[Music]
of right now
you know if you didn't get to be good to
your sister go be good to someone else's
sister you know
i don't know i don't know what i'm
saying i guess but
but sometimes i don't have to look real
far to find what
you don't have to look as far as i think
and um yeah i'm just really inspired i'm
inspired by these moms
and i'm inspired by dads too i know
they're single dads people say they get
on me but
but you know i can't you know we do what
we can man
and just a lot of beautiful cool bad ass
chicks out there and we get to know him
a little bit
that's cool man we're gonna go out today
on a hit man you know this man
and he might even be able to you know in
nashville maybe be able to get him to do
some live tracks or do something special
who knows
i believe he lives over there and this
song man this one gets me every time
you know because i like to play dude i
of course i could play something upbeat
for you but you know i want something
that's gonna damn rinse ya baby
i'm trying to freaking get them eyeballs
empty dog you know daddy
um but
uh this is uh the devil god in me
and this is by evan bartels
man i love this song and i love you
and thank you for being a part of my
week thank you for being a part of my
life
thank you for supporting this little
adventure of this podcast
and yeah and thanks for just for
listening and thinking with me today and
i'm just thinking about just getting
back to my roots you know
you know i don't want to forget the
things that made me care about doing
this
in the first place or forget the things
that i care about
you know when this whole pandy happened
or whatever i think i just got scared
and i think when my career got busy i
got scared
who am i supposed to be who what do i
what do i do now who who am i
uh i started worrying more [ __ ] about
the business
um
but just lucky to have reminders
and i'm glad we put some reminders in
place in the beginning
uh
so that i can remember because nothing
makes me really
really really really nothing makes me
feel better i think than caring about
other people
it's just sometimes you got to just tr
you got to remember you got to work that
muscle
so anyway i'm rambling but be good to
yourself you know you deserve it
and uh and if there's a relationship in
your past that you weren't able to have
just remake it
you know remake it somewhere else
you know we're all just wandering around
we're all loose ends and
we just got to tie on to each other man
we can do it this is evan bartels the
devil
god and me
[Music]
this is a great big
we the people have that choice
[Music]
and mother may i rest my head
though i did not try my
best amen
mother may i slip the wine
[Music]
oh
you can come for me
[Music]
oh
you can't comfort me
[Music]
blame
come on man come on the crown of
lies i wear in shape
what i would give to track
man man the crown of lies i wear in
shame baby
[Music]
[Laughter]
you can come for me come on
[Music]
but you can't comfort me
and you can check out the rest of that
tomb man that's evan bartels
the devil god and
me and you can listen to the rest of
that uh
beautiful hit at uh evan bartels go look
him up his the link to his album
a promise to land and the devil god in
me
linked to them albums will be in the
information
but yeah it's funny man we're talking in
the beginning about grabbing your bag
you know
and then we're also talking about
getting back to your roots
and there's no stronger source of roots
on a man
than his nuts or his bag
amen of that